and finally new rule you can get
creative with a novel a tv show or a
movie but history books
that's not supposed to be fan fiction
how we teach our kids history has become
a big controversy these days with
liberals accusing conservatives of
wanting to whitewash the past and
sometimes that's true sometimes they do
but plenty of liberals also want to
abuse history to control the present and
last month a scholar named james sweet
caught hell for calling them out for
doing just that he criticized the
phenomenon known as presentism
which means judging everyone in the past
by the standards of the present it's the
belief that people who lived a hundred
or five hundred or a thousand years ago
really should have known better
[Applause]
which is so stupid it's like getting mad
at yourself for not knowing what you
know now when you were 10.
stupid me spending all that time raising
sea monkeys and
playing with slot cards and jerking off
to a playboy in the barn
who doesn't have moments from your past
that make you cringe
who hasn't said i can't believe i said
that i can't believe i wore that i can't
believe i thought that i can't believe i
did that
you ate dirt
you wanted to be a ghostbuster you
shoplifted gum
you tried to be a white break dancer you
you wanted to marry scott baio
[Applause]
i read ann rand
i smoked
i was into numerology
yes because we hadn't then grown into
the persons we would become and humanity
writ large
is just the collective version of that
did columbus commit atrocities of course
but people back then were generally
atrocious
[Applause]
everybody who could afford one had a
slave including people of color
the way people talk about slavery these
days you'd think it was a uniquely
american thing that we invented in 1619
but slavery throughout history has been
the rule not the exception
the sumerians the egyptians the greeks
romans the arabs
british the early americans all the way
up through r kelly
[Applause]
the holy bible is practically an owner's
manual for slaveholders the word slave
comes from slav
because so many slavic people were
enslaved and they're as white as the
hallmark channel
who do you think gathered the slaves
from the interior of africa to sell to
slave traders africans who also kept
their own slaves we're a species prone
to making others of our species our
[ __ ]
i've said it before and i'll say it
again humans are not good people
[Applause]
and the capacity for cruelty is a human
thing not a white thing
that's the truth
even though it doesn't jibe with the
current narrative
but in today's world when truth
conflicts with narrative
it's the truth that has to apologize
being woke is like a magic moral time
machine where you judge everybody
against what you imagine you would have
done in 1066 and you always win
presentism
yeah this professor is right it's just a
way to congratulate yourself about being
better than george washington because
you have a gay friend and he didn't
but
but if he was alive today he would too
and if you weren't alive if you were
alive then you wouldn't
portland public schools has a plan now
to teach kids that the idea of gender
being mainly binary was brought here by
white colonizers
the curriculum guide says when the
united states was colonized by white
settlers their views around gender were
forced upon the people already living
here not even star trek would try that
story
where they discover a planet and give
them separate bathrooms
it's like they finally discovered a
unified theory of wokeness
incorporating all their ideas about race
gay gender and colonizers like the new
world was a great big diverse dance club
and the pilgrims were the bridge and
tunnel crowd who came in and ruined
everything
there's a play called i joan currently
being presented in london written by
charlie josephine who identifies as
non-binary and uses they them pronouns
and it portrays joan of arc as surprise
non-binary with they them pronouns
which if you think about it makes even
less sense because joan being french
spoke a language where every noun is
masculine or feminine
joan says in the play i'm not a girl i
don't fit that word as if she's a
character on euphoria
now it's true joan of arc did wear pants
but that's what the soldiers wore and
she was soldiering
but in the retelling
joan would rather die than stop wearing
men's clothing
okay joan of arc wasn't executed by the
fashion police
[Applause]
her trial went on for over two months we
have the transcript and not once did she
complain about being misgendered
she had bigger fish to fry like herself
[Laughter]
too soon it was 1431.
[Applause]
which is not to say that there isn't
truth to the old rubric that history is
written by the winners and it is
subjective napoleon said history is just
a fable we all agree on
and he should know because he was a deaf
woman named diane
but it's also true that much of history
is indisputably factual because we have
artifacts and coins and birth records
and archaeology and somebody in
mesopotamia kept a record of how much
grain they ate
it's not all up in the air to change or
delete or make up based on what makes
you feel better today
a couple of years ago they made a movie
called the aeronaut about the scientists
who broke the record for the highest
altitude in a balloon in fact they were
both men but the movie made one of them
a woman because as the director
explained representation is important
so true
women never get enough credit for the
things they didn't do
i think meryl streep should play
seabiscuit so every girl will know she
too can grow up to be a racehorse
you